die stadt zürich liegt neuerdings am
meer große hafen poller warten auf einen
imaginierten ozeanriesen der vielleicht
bald mal kommen mag ja neuerdings steht
auch am hafen kann hier in zürich und
bald schon werden schiffs hörner das
tuten von schiffshorn die zürcher
möglicherweise mit fernweh erfüllen
ja natürlich ist verwandelt viele freute
es viele ärgert es auch manche
amüsiertes denn bevor es soweit war
bevor es hier so weit war dass der
hafenkran stand ja da wurde sechs jahre
lang politisch gerungen jetzt steht
und bevor ich mich meinen beiden gästen
zuwende
hier ein kurzer einblick ins geschehen
eines nachts waren sie da die riesigen
rostigen teile des hafen krans und
wurden aufgebaut
angefangen hat alles 2009 mit einem
wettbewerb für kunst im öffentlichen
raum
die stadt zürich wollte ein kunstwerk am
limmatquai eine neue sicht auf die
altstadt entstehen lassen
jetzt steht der hafenkran und die
meinungen sind geteilt
strafen katalog verloren findet dass
herr und aber nicht aufzugeben
demnach leiden und zuschnitt miksits
zürich liegt am meer
eine schöne vorstellung
das dachten auch die initianten der
kunstaktion zürich transit maritim um
den autor jan morgenthaler
unterstützt wurden sie dabei von sp
stadtrat war der sogar mit privatem geld
einsparen doch es regte sich heftiger
widerstand bei der bürgerlichen parteien
der streit mit dem haus für die
weltoffenheit demonstrieren und das
canada go das für die
selbstverwirklichung von reitlehrer
gierig aus stadtbild verschandelt wird
und beide stürzten 1000 finanzieren nach
fünf jahren debatte kam das kunstprojekt
an doch zustande
auch dank stadtrat getroffen und mir
handels mit absicht mit dem projekt im
öffentlichen raum immer begehrt und es
ist teil von dem projekt ist die debatte
um was was passiert im öffentlichen raum
wirkt seriös wie aus zürich zur türe
wurde
was könnt die theorie werde das ist dass
ich die bauten im öffentlichen raum um
ihren stimulieren ja und jetzt sitzen
wir hier mitten in zürich an zu
erschöpft zur schifflände sozusagen mit
blick auf den hafenkran sie mit online
ist direktorin der kunsthochschule das
ganze wallis eine kurze schule die unter
anderem den forschungsschwerpunkt kunst
im öffentlichen raum hat und martin
waser ehemals sp stadtrat der stadt
zürich und ja eigentlich mit initiator
und treibende kraft hinter diesem
kunstprojekt von dem wir jetzt haben
werden martin waser sie haben vor sechs
jahren dieses projekt mit angestoßen und
seite mit unglaublich viel herzblut
betrieben auch ein stück weit am ende
sogar noch eigenes geld mit 1 geschossen
also drohte zu kippen warum so
unglaublich viel herzblut
also ich glaube grundsätzlich bin ich
einfach so sagt wenn ich etwas wirklich
anstoße will ich jetzt auch zu ende
bringen und überhaupt auch mein einsatz
wichtig also nicht ich habe jetzt zwölf
jahre fließen stadt gearbeitet
aber meine ganze lebenskraft sage ich
jetzt mal investiert dann will man auch
resultate sehen dinge die man stets
trägt zum erfolg bringen und da bin ich
jetzt sehr glücklich dass das
tatsächlich auch zustande gekommen ist
zürich transit maritim heißt das ganze
projekt und ein teil dieses projekts ist
ja eben dieser heftig umstrittene
hafenkran der herr lehmann ufer steht
sie willkommen als sie diesen hafenkran
diesen frostigen hafen kann schon sagen
wissen gebrauchten hafenkran gesehen
haben was hat er in ihnen ausgelöst
also ich bin gestern mit der tram vom
bahnhof her kommend gefahren und
eigentlich meine erste reaktion war da
ist ja gar nicht so groß wie ich gedacht
habe weil auf den fotos und in den
modellen sieht sieht das auch sehr viel
imposanter aus muss man sagen und das
ist ja oft auch eine 1 1
ein umstand der eben kunst im
öffentlichen raum ja auch so aufregend
macht dass es geht um mass tätigkeiten
um verschiebungen von maßstäben und
daher war ich zuerst etwas überrascht
dass es ein ding ist das sicher ein
bisschen fremd hier steht und ein
bisschen auch ein neues element ist weil
ich kannte zürich auch ohne diesen
hafenkran aber die maßstäblichkeit ist
mich sofort ins auge gesprungen
da liegt ja auch nur neun monate hier
stehen und hat unglaublich viel
widerstand ausgelöst es muss man schon
sagen martin waser eigentlich von anfang
an als es klar dass das hier entstehen
soll da war von sadismus die rede total
daneben was soll das diese stadt
verschandelung vor allem auch von
bürgerlicher seite kam will viel
widerstand aber inzwischen natürlich
regen sich auch künstler die nicht alle
damit einverstanden aber salz begeistert
er natürlich auch es wurde massiv
gestritten vor allem auch
finanzpolitisch aber was sagen
eigentlich die absicht damals 2008 als
ein wettbewerb ausgeschrieben
um dort etwas hinzusetzen und dort etwas
zu bewegen an dieser stelle also
eigentlich war und der gewinner hat
einen wettbewerbsbeitrag gemacht die
eigentlich gar nicht legal war er wollte
nämlich dort wo hoffen kann steht ein
gebäude hinstellen 1 1
klaus einen glaskubus und das hat schon
heftige reaktionen ausgelöst oder das
stand früher die die fleischer aus einem
gebäude stand das stand ein volumen da
und wir waren da ein bisschen raus
lassen hatte intensiv diskutiert ob das
jetzt auch realisieren soll oder nicht
hat sich da nicht einigen können steht
ist auch nichts und trotzdem ist klar
dass dieser platz ist er ist nicht
wirklich definiert die die die nutzung
im städtischen kontext ist nicht
wirklich definiert da muss die gemüse
brücke die in unmittelbarer
nachbarschaft ist muss in nächster zeit
auch ersetzt werden
und das war dann eigentlich die idee man
macht machen wir doch etwas
außergewöhnliches das unorthodoxe oft um
not ops werde schreiben einen
mitbewerber ein internationaler
wettbewerb für eine kunst intervention
hat und diese diskussion noch einmal zu
befruchten und dann in 15 jahren eine
städtebauliche städtebauliche lösung zu
finden die dann sicher auch erstritten
werden muss aber diesen schritt weiter
lassen sie uns über kunst im
öffentlichen raum reden jetzt in den
nächsten 20 minuten mir geht es
eigentlich im wesentlichen um drei
fragen also zunächst mal was soll und
kann kunst im öffentlichen raum
eigentlichen heißen überhaupt dann ist
auch die frage was ist uns kunst im
öffentlichen raum als gesellschaft wert
und vielleicht tatsächlich als letztes
auch die frage ja was lernen wir denn
aus diesem ganzen projekt und vielleicht
um hier erstmal anzusetzen
die frage was kann kunst im öffentlichen
raum leisten ist doch zunächst die frage
was unterscheidet den kunst im
öffentlichen raum von kunst im
geschlossenen raum sprechen museen
sie würden also ich denke dass kunst
hier eindeutig eine art zwischenposition
einnimmt also es ist eben nicht mehr nur
die autonome funktionslose kunst die im
museum ästhetischen diskurs anstoßen
will
der ästhetische erfahrungen erlebnisse
vermitteln will
in einem definierten raum wird für diese
frauen vorgesehen ist sondern kunst im
öffentlichen raum versucht den gerade
dieses 2 dazwischen eine man kann schon
sagen es ist vielleicht eine art von
funktionalität die die kunst will einen
dialog mit der gesellschaft das auch mit
der politik mit der politischen bürger
anstoßen auslösen aber es gibt sicher
immer auch noch dieser hauptaufgabe der
kunst es soll auch eine ästhetische
erfahrung natürlich sein also eine
erfahrung die das sehen anregt die
wahrnehmung weiß ich nicht genau ob ich
mit diesen gefahren auch dass eben diese
dieses anstoßen von wahrnehmung generell
ist der kunst immer inhärent und diese
diese aufgabe hat die kunst auch im
öffentlichen raum natürliches ist eine
ästhetische setzung auch immer als kann
auch eine aktion seien eine handlung die
immer etwas auslöst etwas bewegt der
raum aber wo dieses geschieht ist eben
kein neutraler raum ich denke auch der
museumsraum letztendliches kein absolut
neutrale raum
aber es ist ein raum der bürger der
bürgerinnen
und da entstehen natürlich auch ganz
andere fragen an ganz andere auch
thematiken zum teil auch probleme und da
gibt es diesen diese auseinandersetzung
dann auf mit diesen werken mit diesen
projekten kann man auch sagen natürlich
die gegner von seinem hafen kann ja
moment mal ein hafenkran bitteschön ein
rostiges teil das ist doch keine kunst
da kann ich natürlich als spezialistin
argumentieren aufgrund der geschichte
und sagen wir haben auch kunstwerke die
sind einige sogenannte readymades also
objekte die bereits existieren werden
aus kunst definiert sie werden
verschoben von einem raum in den anderen
das gehört zur kunst das ist immer
wieder auch ein thema gewesen in der
zeitgenössischen kunst also ich habe
keine probleme dieses diesen hafen kann
aus kunstwerk zu definierenden für in
meinem kontext das ist klar weil das
kunstwerk um den kontext an spezialisten
verlässt ist klar dass es auch für einen
einen mal ein normalbürger eine normale
bürgerin der sicher fragen aus löst das
rätsel löst bis heute fragen auch das
von die chance etwas passieren das sind
eigentlich nach wie vor fragen die uns
beschäftigen auch in der
zeitgenössischen kunst also was ist
überhaupt ein kunstwerk wie minimal kann
es sein wie reduziert die konzeptuell
wie ästhetisch also das sind die alten
farben die kunst nach wie vor stellen
diese readymades seinerzeit in paris
muss die haben auch heftige diskussionen
ausgelöst wurden angefeindet
so gesehen martin waser könnte man ja
sagen eigentlich diese politische
debatte die jetzt im vorfeld
stattgefunden hat die sich über sechs
jahre hingezogen habe ist eine schon ein
teil auch dieses kunstwerks war das eine
absicht dahinter steckte versteckt nein
es ist ein schönes zusammentreffen an
die in zwei jahren feiert hatte ich
natürlich dann 100 jahre dadaismus aus
indien
dabei ist die stadt zürich geboren
worden von daher passt es natürlich sehr
wohl
diese stadt ich möchte noch einige
anmerkungen zum öffentlichen raum hat
sich 2002 ins amt kommt hat mir einen
riesigen investitionsstau aus den 90er
jahren aus der stadt sehr schlecht
gegessen hat nun die aufgabe diese
öffentlichen räume neu zu gestalten zu
renovieren
auch welchen frei zu spielen und in
diesem kontext stellte sich dann auch
ein paar jahren mir die frage klinik
noch ein bisschen mehr machen als
einfach räume zu gestalten habe ich dann
intensiv mit den stadt träumen
auseinandergesetzt meine man kann in
allen städten kommen an die geschichte
in der rechtlichen räumen ablesen die
öffentlichen räumen für das stadtleben
eine extrem wichtige aufgabe hier
treffen die verschiedensten schichten
menschen auseinander setzen sich
miteinander auseinander das macht die
kreativität die die die lebendigkeit der
städte aus in diesem kontext leben zeigt
kunstwerke oder kunst zu installieren
finde ich ganz wichtig alles im gerade
diese städtische urbane diskussion
befruchtet und beleben die diesem
kontext würde ich diese diese
installation auf jeden fall stellen und
das war mir auch einander herzlich
wollte nicht nur einfach neu teeren und
neue neue randsteine setzen und wirklich
die die stadt die stadt räume neu
gestalten
ich meine die stadt zürich hat sich
jetzt meiner sicht das ist ja nicht nur
mein verdienst sondern auch der
fachleute alter der gestalter und
architekten stadtplaner die in der stadt
sich in den letzten zehn 15 jahren
gewirkt haben zu verdanken
natürlich eine sehr attraktive stadt
gewohnt ist die möglichen raum und ich
finde eben was es braucht wenn man kunst
im öffentlichen raum ersetzt 18
besondere sorgfalt einmal nicht
ausreichen können museum kann ich extrem
provokative dinge erste da kann man auch
wieder raus laufen und dann ist es weg
und darum provoziert wahrscheinlich
man kann nicht aussagen alle menschen
sehen die möglichen man muss sich damit
auseinandersetzen und von daher muss ich
sagen wenig 18 positiver positiv
überrascht und wirklich aggressiv ist es
da nicht auf der straße sicher stark
gewesen hatten leuten diskutiert dann
kommen sie ist das kunst und sonntag
erst gar nicht richtig was meinen sie
dazu löw erinnert und es gibt ganz
interessante diskussion
einer derjenigen die sich von anfang an
nicht zur wehr gesetzt haben ist der
künstler gottfried honegger konkret
konstruktivistische künstler jahrgang
1917 hat sich zu wort gemeldet mit einem
zitat bei dem sie gerne konfrontieren
möchte hat nämlich gesagt ich bin der
überzeugung dass wir kunstwerke baut
damit meint auch kunstwerke im
öffentlichen raum kunstwerke brauchen
die uns durch form und haltung werte
geben für unser leben
ein kran die keine werte reagieren sie
darauf
ich erkenne dahinter natürlich eine auch
eine ästhetische werthaltung von einem
künstler gottfried honegger verkörpern
und ich habe ganz klare ästhetische
positionen die mit ihm machen für ihn
mit wert verbunden ist
ich denke heute ist es sehr viel
schwieriger reden von werthaltigkeit in
der kunst acht versprechen wir haben
einen solchen pluralismus der
erscheinungsweise auch von kunst im
öffentlichen raum heute also wir haben
die klassische culturale setzung die
große skulpturale geste á la sera bis
hin zu aktionen im sinne eines nicola
brio der von relationalen oder sozial
bezogener kunst spricht was er eine
performance oder eine aktion im
öffentlichen raum ist da ist es auch
schwieriger geworden von solchen klar
ästhetischen erfahrungen und wertungen
und auch fast in einem moralischen sehen
also dass er dir die erhebung durch die
kunst das im sinne von cannes zu
sprechen heute sowieso
aber ich muss auch zugeschrieben dass
sie sicher sind das entspricht einem
empfinden und auf jeden fall kutscher
auf jeden fall ist es auch ein
ästhetisches erleben da hätten dass es
eben vorliegen gibt für klare setzungen
auch ästhetische setzungen ich
persönlich habe auch gerne also klare
minimalistische skulpturen ist gehört
auch zu meinen lieblings gegenständen
der kunst die ich sehe im öffentlichen
raum oder in immer
auch im museum oder auch ich hab auch
gerne andere erfahrungen von kunst
ich denke schon dass die wertefrage
vielleicht nicht nur im sinne von einer
moralischen wertigkeit gestellt werden
muss sondern von einer see erfahrung
oder auch von einer erfahrung von etwas
visuellen das eben denkanstöße auslöst
das gibt ihnen auch ein stichwort
stecher anstöße angst auszulösen
täglich ich schätze ihn sehr und haben
großen respekt
man muss ja nicht immer einverstanden
teil nur alleine eine kunst kapazität
ist ich bin ich bin nicht grundsätzlich
mit dieser aussage sind generell wenn
sie abstrakt und generell gelten so
nicht einverstanden
ich denke man muss aufpassen dass nicht
nicht eben nicht statisch ist ich starte
ich diskutiert oder sieht jetzt steht
der chor freilich ist der kran einreißen
das projekt heißt ja zürich transit
maritim
woher kommen wir wohin gehen wir stell
dir ganz viele existenzielle fragen auch
mit diesen projekten durch meine der
steht jetzt hier neun monate und dann
geht er wieder und dann wird er ein
gegossen und dann ist erweckt wurde
und das finde ich spannend erst und dann
wird man durch sie sind damit diese
dieser ort ganz neu wahrgenommen
das denke ich ist doch eine chance für
die städtebauliche diskussion die nicht
die meiner ansicht nach noch erfolgen
muslimen ist neuer anschaut da jetzt
etwas fehlt es sich etwas weg und das
denke das gibt er hinweise über die
gestaltung ist dieses stadtrat ja
trotzdem autobauer soll ich meine dieses
projekt zürich transit maritim sechs
jahre genesungs geschichte das wurde
auch schon bis rot grüne zwängerei
bezeichnet es wurden 6000 stimmen
gesammelt dagegen die kam dann zu spät
die initiative greift nicht mehr
sie haben am ende sogar eben selber noch
etwas geld eingeschossen 80.000 bank das
wird ein bisserl weniger weil noch
spendengelder zugekommen sind aber
trotzdem die frage lohnt sich so viel
geld so viel emotionen für diesen
diskurs sehen sie jetzt gerade ein
massaker eine größenordnung
größenordnung zum geld pro kopf geben
ihr einen franken 50 erst als einfach
das relativiert schon bis kann diese das
ist ein großer lärm und redet wenig
mittel
ich dachte ich da geht es nämlich nicht
mehr so gut wie vielleicht noch vor vier
jahren ich denke es absolut
verantwortbar und ich finde ja es lohnt
sich
es lohnt sich finde ich gerade diese
diskussionen sie führen uns auch weiter
die auseinandersetzung mit
unterschiedlichen haltungen
werthaltungen das bild jener das gehört
zur stadt das gehört zur urbanität und
was das was ich feststelle hier wirklich
an diesem ort dass die menschen hören
einander zu sie schreien sich nicht an
sie hören einander zu sie gehen
aufeinander ein
manchmal kaum jemanden überzeugen
manchmal licht ist auch okay aber die
auseinandersetzung die findet statt und
ich habe es noch nie erlebt jetzt in den
letzten zehn 15 jahren das wirklich
stadtgespräch ist und dass sich das
projekt geschafft und das fluge das
schaffe ich es wirklich große qualität
dimension nämlich alles stadtmarketing
also wenn wir jetzt vom wert sprechen
darf
die große frage lohnt sie ist ein
kunstwerk für die stadt zürich und für
das tourismusmarketing vermutlich
relativ großartig oder sie haben sich
auch mit diesen versprechen von
auseinandergesetzt
also ich muss sagen da wird es mir
natürlich immer ein bisschen schwindlig
wenn ich meine wenn die kunst im
öffentlichen raum eben schon die
funktion haben sollte diskurse
anzustoßen eben über städtebau über
stadt an sich ist das finde ich
eigentlich das ist ein
gesellschaftlicher diskurs
da bin ich eigentlich sehr auch
einverstanden damit auch ich habe immer
ein bisschen angst um die kunst dass man
ihr zu viel auf lädt also sie haben von
der gemüse brücke gerät also ich
städtebauliches problem ungelöst das
dann meine kunst etwas gelöst haben so
ich denke sich der falsche weg
auch wenn man sagt das was braucht jetzt
marketingmaßnahmen für zürich über kunst
ich bin da immer ein bisschen skeptisch
weil kunst ist auch kunst und marketing
ist marketing oder videos ich bin
überhaupt kein freund von morgen die ich
denke die stadt zürich braucht es auch
nicht
also das ist ein alter in ein
nebenaspekt wenn wir überhaupt ein
wichtiger wichtiger nebenaspekt ja aber
der see in den haben wir nicht bezirk
des chaos geben dann tritt wie sie diese
chance nutzen das haus kommen demnach
nicht verbieten das ist halt so und ich
denke die kunst muss nichts
ich habe vielleicht ergibt sich etwas
vielleicht ergibt sich nichts daraus
bezüglich steht ist diese dieser 60 mal
gestalterischen fragen
das ist auch okay aber auf jeden fall es
bleibt etwas in der geschichte der stadt
zürich zurück in den köpfen gibt es gibt
ein anderes bild der stadt das bleibt in
unseren köpfen die geschichten es gibt
ganz viele menschen die die wollen jetzt
weitere geleistet gibt ganz viele
aktivitäten im kontext von von dieser
von dieser dienst aus und da bin ich
jetzt sehr gespannt was da was da noch
reinhard auch und künstlich jetzt
erfolgen
das sind ganz viele dinge noch passieren
man darf sich auch nicht deshalb dass es
jetzt 1 1 ist es ja nicht erhoffen kann
alleine sondern sind auch noch schiffs
signalhörner die zuhören werden sein
werde ab mai es ist ein großer spieler
der in der landschaft am nordufer steht
und quasi so die ankunft eines
imaginierten roth ozeanriesen
vorwegnimmt setzen wir haben es vorhin
gesagt martin waser am anfang des
wettbewerbs stand auch der anspruch an
eine breite städtebauliche debatte bis
jetzt wurde aber im wesentlichen
gestritten um finanzen und um diese
nicht wirklich lösbare frage was ist
kunst die städtebauliche debatte muss
ich sagen ja ziel nicht erreicht oder
noch nicht erreicht also das ist dass
geld mir dann in zwei jahren beurteilen
dann bin ich sehr gelassen ich bin
sicher dass theaters die kommt da bin
ich ganz sicher ob die wichtig aber wie
gesagt ich würde es nicht so elitär ist
sich aneinander binden
das ist eine eigenständige geschichte
und ich denke da passiert ganz viel
engagieren sich ganz viele leute es ist
auch interessant wie gewisse widerstände
wegbrechen und wenn man jetzt auch die
lima chart sieht man diese leitlinie
prozent ein tief 1 1 ein coup der zuerst
sehr sehr skeptisch reagiert hat und in
kurzer zeit haben sie begonnen so
geschichten zu entwickeln und dann
hafenrundfahrten anbieten werden also
oder schiff stechen dass man von der
zunft gemacht für diese absichtlich dann
in diesem kontext hier gestellt es gibt
ganz viele die diesen ball jetzt
aufgreifen und selber aktivität sind
das ist wunderschön sie lernen brauchen
wir an falls mehr diese art von kunst
anregung im öffentlichen raum als sie
eigentlich haben weil die tatsache dass
ich jetzt so viele diskutanten auf
dieses thema gestürzt haben verpasst er
möglicherweise auch auf ein bedürfnis
darauf über diese bilder diskutiert
ich möchte auch noch etwas anknüpfen was
er gesagt hat und dann auf ihre frage
antworten ich glaube wir brauchen vor
allem sehr präzise interventionen
man kann nicht irgendetwas machen im
öffentlichen raum also wir sind heute
nicht mehr so naiv und zu sagen ja ich
stelle es da mal einen kran hin und
schaue was das passiert in meinen augen
und das ist auch eine kritik an sich
sind an diesem projekt das ist so ein
bisschen ein luftballon was macht eine
große symbolische setzung und schaut
dann ja was entzündet sich daran also
ich finde heute hat der künstler die
künstlerin auch die verantwortung mit
einer solchen setzung gerade im
städtischen kontext sich zu belegen
welche frage stoße ich an was löse ich
damit aus wie kann ich diese kann diese
diskussion eben auch dann führen als
künstler da steht der künstler sich
künstlerin in der verantwortung da kann
er sich nicht hinaus ziehen und einfach
so diese luftballons staaten diese
zeiten sind in meinen augen ein bisschen
vorbei war wir haben sehr viel erfahren
über kunst im öffentlichen raum
wir haben auch gute beispiele wir haben
erfahrungen von anderen projekten
also ich hätte mir gar nicht gewöhnt
dass die auch von den künstlerinnen
künstlern diese städtebauliche diskurs
denn sie auch vorhat mehr wollten dass
sie den doch ein bisschen auch ebenso
anbinden an einer städtebauliche frage
und hier ist vor allem sowie das projekt
verstehen gelesen habe so die das
imaginäre dass hier vor allem
angestoßen werden soll die fantasie das
träumen ich finde ich auch okay
interessiert mich jetzt ein bisschen
weniger als experte aus kunst genießerin
als kunstexperte ich mag den crown ich
mache den poller rang ich noch mehr der
poller ist ja schon länger da das war so
eine sehr feine sich eine sehr feine
setzung aber ich denke jetzt kommt
dieser tief kur sollte und da sind die
kunstschaffenden in der verantwortung
auch und da werde ich genau hinschauen
auch wie das jetzt sind jetzt ankündigt
beteiligen sie sich weniger über ihre
motive und so zu diskutieren über den
haufen kran hinaus und das andere mit
ihnen diskutieren ich denke ich dass das
so unverbindlich ist habe ich nicht die
fantasie dass sie sonst keinen raum
geben wir kommen langsam zum schluss
unseres gesprächs davon dass es keinen
raum geben werden wir sind am anfang
der hafen kann ist jetzt erst mal
aufgebaut wird neun monate stehen ganz
kurz ihre prognose werden zuerst phase
werden wir werden die zürcher in neun
monaten möglicherweise sich gegen den
abbau des hafens während also die
zürcher so gibt es ja nicht
verwirklichen jede keine homogene
gesellschaft aber es gibt sicher greife
geben die das verlangen werden es gibt
bereits habe ich in der zeitung gelesen
eine gruppierung der die jusos die die
findet der traum muss da bleiben dass
jede sicher geben da wie nicht
dezidierte meinung der muss weiter
ziehen sonst stimmte geschichte für mich
nicht das finde ich ganz wichtig er
kommt und geld und nachher wissen wir
uns dann auch wieder selbst ins gesicht
und und uns überlegen was macht mir zeit
ihnen leben in dieser stadt zürich
transit maritim noch ein ganz kurzer
prognose von sibylle omlin wird am
schluss möglicherweise sogar bisschen
mit herzblut noch an diesem haben kann
ja den alpenkamm nachgebaut werden
ich denke es ist eine eine ästhetische
auch soziale setzung die tatsächliches
einem einfach macht sich dazu zu
positionieren
ihn zu lieben ihn zu hassen
ich finde vor allem interessant diese
politischen dimensionen die dieser kann
angestoßen hat und ich habe geschichte
gefolgt verfolgt über die zeitung also
dass es eine politische aktion gibt auch
wenn das jetzt nicht aus der ecke kommt
die ich mir gewünscht hätte aber das ist
das ist demokratie dass es eine debatte
gibt und dass man auch spuren von dieser
debatte hat es gibt ja eine initiative
glaube ich die erzählen zukunft auch
hafenkräne als kunstobjekt verbieten
will dass ich mein ich aus experten fiel
so etwas absolut genial das ist reine
konzeptkunst kann man sagen was da
passieren aber nicht bewusste denken
denn hin
also ich denke es ist zeigt dass wir uns
auf einen weg bewegen in kunst im
öffentlichen raum wo ihm auch die
künstler in künstler tatsächlich diese
diskussion suchen und das finde ich
eigentlich eine gute sache
also wir dürfen gespannt sein und sind
es auch tatsächlich zuging und martin
waser ganz herzlichen dank dieses
gespräch finden sie selbstverständlich
auch auf unserer website und dort finden
sie auch ein reichhaltiges dossier mit
prominenten stimmen zum fischerhafen kam
und auch die sendung kulturplatz am
nächsten mittwoch wird sich ausführlich
dem thema kunst im öffentlichen raum zu
wenden
die jetzt noch einen blick auf nächsten
sonntag in der sternstunde religion
übertragen wir den evangelisch
reformierten gottesdienst aus
friedensdorf dann eine sternstunde
philosophie sprechen wir mit dem
schriftsteller lukas bärfuss über die
atemlosigkeit unserer zeit und darüber
ob sie ein ausweg daraus findet und
schließlich feiern wir 450 jahre
shakespeare mit einem film der es einige
fragezeichen setzt sie sehen uns